Mlle Murphey, cela fait 120 jours depuis
votre dernier paiement. Je suis un agriculteur. Je ne peux pas
vous payer jusqu'à ce que mes récoltes soient déjà un leader
dont les rêves sont passés.  football
hé oh es-tu fou ils sont ensemble quel
genre de question est que si je voyais ma
flamme de lycée avec mon meilleur ami
je pourrais me demander qu'une famille inquiète pour
l'avenir ferait mieux de mettre ces haricots
avant que la pluie n'arrive ici tu n'es pas  le
seul à avoir du mal en ce moment
voudriez-vous descendre sur le terrain où cela
signifie quelque chose pourquoi ne vous inquiétez-vous pas
pour vos champs ne vous inquiétez pas pour les miens
mais quelque chose est sur le point de se produire dans l'
eau froide quelque chose d'inattendu quelque chose d'
inexplicable quelque chose d'étonnant Scotty
viens  on va être en retard
attends ce que
hey toi d'accord ah c'était tellement vrai coach
madame c'est vrai tu sais même
pourquoi il est toujours tard tout comme ton père
maman tu es puni Buster je suis puni
peut-être que c'est  fou ce n'est pas une sorte
de vie après la mort chose nous sommes
ici je suis réel ton vrai fils ne me fais
pas commencer à tester des drogues que donnerais-
tu pour avoir une chance de le refaire je
veux que tu sois un  homme qui est bon pour plus
d'une nuit par semaine un  Tout ce que j'ai toujours
voulu faire, c'est jouer au football maintenant, j'ai
une chance de le refaire. Je n'abandonne
pas Ronny Presley Kurt Russell
Melanie Lynskey et Christine Lahti si vous ne pouvez pas
être satisfait de ce que vous avez et
vous '  Je ne serai jamais heureux d'
avoir une petite amie ouais mais je ne l'épouse pas
je t'épouse
tu n'as pas porté cette équipe ici tu les as dirigées
je gâche ma vie pour un
match de football au lycée
je peux t'emmener avec lui
te toucher en retour